Buonasera, ho spostato il microfono, se non va bene ditemelo, mi raccomando.
Allora, ci sono tre professioni che hanno il diritto di portare la toga, il giudice, il prete e lo studioso.
Quest'abito attesta la maturità mentale di chi lo porta, la sua indipendenza di giudizio e la sua diretta responsabilità verso la sua coscienza e il suo Dio.
Significa la sovranità interiore di queste tre professioni, che sono collegate fra loro.
Sono le ultime che dovrebbero accettare di agire sotto costrizione e cedere alle pressioni.
Ecco, era uno che la prendeva un po' alta, Ernst Kantorowicz, ma come vedrete, in vita sua ha avuto delle occasioni buone per affermare questo tipo di impegno.
Lui non era né un magistrato né un prete, era uno studioso.
Questo tipo di impegno dello studioso che risponde soltanto alla sua coscienza e al suo Dio se ne ha uno e non ad altri, vedremo a chi.
Ernst Kantorowicz è sicuramente meno noto dei due studiosi che abbiamo raccontato nei giorni scorsi.
Fra noi medievisti è molto conosciuto, è uno storico che ha scritto alcuni libri molto importanti.
Di nascita è tedesco.
Nasce in una città che i tedeschi chiamano Posen e che i polacchi chiamano Poznan e che oggi è in Polonia,
ma che per molto tempo è stata una città invece tedesca.
Ernst Kantorowicz nasce a Posen nel 1895.
Badate alla data, è un po' più giovane di Mark Bloch, decisamente più giovane di Gaetano Salvemini,
ma non così giovane da scampare a quella data fatale del 1914,
che come sappiamo per due generazioni è stato un momento che ha cambiato la loro vita.
Kantorowicz nasce a Posen da una famiglia ricca,
una famiglia di industriali, produttori di alcolici, famiglia importante, autorevole, hanno mezzi,
il piccolo Ernst ha una governante inglese, cosa che non guasterà come vedrete poi nell'ultima parte della sua vita,
è destinato dalla famiglia a continuare a gestire l'azienda di famiglia,
per cui dopo il liceo lo mandano ad Hamburgo a studiare sostanzialmente economia e commercio.
E' lì, a 19 anni, che si prepara a diventare il gestore di una fabbrica di alcolici,
quando scoppia la prima guerra mondiale.
Lui, rispetto a Salvemini e a Marc Bloch, ha avuto tempo di fare meno cose prima che scoppiasse la guerra.
Parte volontario, si fa i suoi quattro anni di guerra, ferito nella grande battaglia di Verdun,
poi nell'ultimo anno di guerra lo spediscono in uno stato maggiore tedesco a Costantinopoli,
a Istanbul, capitale dell'impero ottomano, alleato della Germania.
In realtà lui è lì a fare una cosa non particolarmente poetica,
costruiscono delle ferrovie a uso militare.
Ma intanto si fa l'ultimo anno di guerra a Istanbul e scopre questo mondo orientale,
questo mondo musulmano, che lo colpisce molto,
tanto che nel dopoguerra, da studente universitario,
deciderà di fare una tesi di laurea sulle corporazioni nel mondo islamico.
Bene, fin qua è sopravvissuto alla guerra.
Se facciamo il confronto con Marc Bloch, di cui abbiamo parlato ieri sera,
e tanti di voi c'erano,
Marc Bloch finisce la guerra e ha vinto.
La Francia ha vinto la guerra.
È un paese pieno di speranze,
anche se poi quelle speranze pian piano nell'arco degli anni 20 e 30
si ridurranno a molto poco.
Però Marc Bloch opera nel dopoguerra in un paese che ha vinto.
Ernst Kantorowicz torna in patria in una Germania sconfitta.
In una Germania sconfitta dove sta succedendo di tutto,
dove il paese è sull'orlo della rivoluzione,
il Kaiser è scappato.
E prima che si arrivi a quel po' di stabilità relativa della Repubblica di Weimar,
si passa attraverso rivoluzioni, contro-rivoluzioni, prove generali di guerra civile.
Kantorowicz,
quanti anni ha?
18, 23 anni.
Kantorowicz, a 23 anni, tornato dalla guerra,
è un nazionalista tedesco convinto e direi addirittura fanatico.
E' uno di quei frontkampfer, come dicono i tedeschi di allora,
combattente del fronte,
che si è portato dietro l'abitudine alla violenza,
l'abitudine all'uso delle armi.
E nella Germania, dell'immediato dopoguerra,
ci sono un sacco di modi di continuare a usarle, le armi.
Sta per scoppiare la rivoluzione, la rivoluzione operaia,
la rivoluzione comunista.
Un amico racconta di una volta che lui e Kantorowicz
sono per strada in divisa e la gente li aggredisce
e gli strappa le spalline dalla divisa.
Talmente forte è l'odio di tanta gente
verso l'esercito dell'imperatore,
che ha perso la guerra, oltretutto.
Kantorowicz torna nella sua città, a Posen,
e scopre che a Posen la popolazione polacca
si è armata e insorta.
Ricordate che fra le mille cose che succedono
alla fine della Prima Guerra Mondiale
è che rinasce uno stato polacco,
che prima non c'era.
Rinasce la Polonia,
con un grosso pezzo che apparteneva all'impero dello Zar
e con pezzi che prima appartenevano all'Austria e alla Germania.
A Posen i polacchi insorgono,
gli abitanti tedeschi formano una milizia armata
per combattere contro i polacchi
e Kantorowicz si arruola.
Combatte contro i polacchi, perdono,
Posen diventa Poznan,
la famiglia Kantorowicz emigra
verso l'interno della Germania,
vanno a Berlino,
Ernst fa giusto in tempo a iscriversi
a filosofia e all'università,
scoppia la rivoluzione comunista a Berlino,
la rivolta spartachista.
Contro la rivolta spartachista si formano,
l'abbiamo detto nel titolo
che è stato letto prima di questa chiacchierata,
i frei corps,
i corpi liberi,
i corpi volontari,
ex soldati ma anche studenti,
nazionalisti inquadrati da ufficiali del Kaiser
che prendono le armi
per stroncare nel sangue
la rivoluzione comunista.
Kantorowicz si arruola,
combatte
e stroncano nel sangue
la rivoluzione comunista.
Ricordate Rosa Luxemburg,
Karl Liebknecht,
un colpo in testa e giù nel fiume.
Deve aver fatto qualche mese di università,
nel gennaio 19 c'è stata la rivoluzione a Berlino,
due mesi,
poi nel marzo 19 scoppia la rivoluzione comunista a Monaco di Baviera,
la Repubblica dei Consigli,
dei Soviet,
Soviet sapete che vuol dire consiglio,
scoppia la rivoluzione bolshevica a Monaco di Baviera,
si arruolano fra i corps,
Kantorowicz si arruola,
va a combattere contro i comunisti
a Monaco di Baviera,
lì viene anche ferito in combattimento.
Qualche anno dopo,
questo giovane studente,
ho detto di filosofia,
perché la filosofia si chiama così la facoltà,
ma lui è storico,
si sente storico fin dall'inizio,
qualche anno dopo ricorderà cosa voleva dire
essere uno storico in Germania nel 1918,
secondo lui,
secondo i ventenni della sua generazione.
Essere uno storico nella Germania in sfacelo
del 1918 con le bandiere rosse in giro,
secondo Kantorowicz voleva dire,
voi capite questo lo dice 12 anni dopo,
quando ha fatto in tempo a calmarsi molto,
ma quando avevo 23 anni dice
essere uno storico voleva dire
avere una fede fanatica nella patria,
nella patria in pericolo,
e il dovere dello storico tedesco,
secondo quello che pensavano loro a vent'anni
in quel momento,
era predicare il dogma
del prestigioso futuro
della nazione tedesca
e del suo onore.
Avete capito il contesto?
In questa Germania,
in crisi di identità spaventosa,
una Germania che era, come dire,
pensate a quella di adesso,
ricca e potente come quella di adesso
e in più armata fino ai denti
e ha perso una grande guerra
ed è ridotta in miseria.
Provate a pensare cosa pensa
la maggior parte dei tedeschi
in quella situazione.
Aspettate solo che ci riprendiamo
e poi la faremo vedere a tutti.
Kantorowicz, per fortuna,
è ricco di famiglia,
studia,
passa da un'università all'altra.
Nelle università tedesche
a quell'epoca,
forse un po' ancora adesso,
ma molto meno,
a quel tempo c'era questa costumanza,
molto bella a suo modo.
Gli studenti universitari
frequentavano diverse università.
Facevano due semestri magari a Berlino,
poi altri due semestri a Heidelberg,
visitavano diversi luoghi del sapere
alla ricerca del loro maestro.
A Heidelberg nel 1920
Ernst Kantorowicz, 25enne,
già con quattro anni di guerra alle spalle
più tre guerre civili,
incontra il suo maestro.
Entra nel circolo di un poeta
famosissimo nella Germania di allora,
noi oggi l'abbiamo totalmente dimenticato,
si chiamava Stefan Gheorghe,
era un poeta famosissimo
che si circondava di giovani,
era un po' quello
che oggi noi considereremmo un guru,
ecco,
un uomo che ha un forte carisma
e che influenza un gruppo
di adepti,
di fedeli,
che pendono dalle sue labbra.
E più che cinquantenne
questo poeta si circonda di giovani,
è una specie di profeta.
cosa predica Stefan Gheorghe
ai giovani come Kantorowicz
nella Germania in sfacelo degli anni venti?
Lui dice,
in realtà,
in realtà la vera Germania
non è quella che vedete.
Esiste un'altra Germania,
una Germania segreta,
che è fatta dei grandi uomini
che sanno essere al di sopra
della contingenza del presente.
La Germania nella sua storia
ha sempre avuto
dei grandi uomini
che sono tutti collegati fra loro
e in futuro un giorno
la Germania segreta trionferà.
Un giorno un'elite,
un'aristocrazia di spiriti nobili,
di artisti,
di saggi,
governerà la Germania
e il mondo.
Ovviamente uno di fronte a tutto questo,
sapendo che siamo in Germania negli anni venti,
si dice
sarà una delle cose
che hanno un po' preparato il nazismo,
per esempio questa cosa qui,
che hanno un po' preparato
il culto del Führer,
ecco.
Non è chiaro,
si discute,
perché molti giovani intellettuali
e aristocratici
e ufficiali tedeschi
sono passati nel circolo
di Stefan Gheorghe
e se uno va a vedere
chi erano i giovani
che lo adoravano,
ci trova qualcuno
che poi è diventato nazista
e ci trova anche tanti ebrei,
per esempio.
Ci trova, per esempio,
ancora
i due fratelli von Stauffenberg
che poi faranno
l'attentato a Hitler
del 20 luglio 1944.
Per carità,
Juncker prussiani,
aristocratici,
ufficiali,
di destra,
conservatori,
nazionalisti,
ma non nazisti.
Quindi ci sono molte cose complicate
dentro questo circolo
di Stefan Gheorghe
dove Kantorowicz
da giovane
si imbeve
di queste idee.
La Germania segreta,
i grandi uomini,
i grandi saggi
e poeti
e artisti
che devono dirigere
il mondo.
Quanto a Stefan Gheorghe
cosa pensava
dei nazisti
non è chiarissimo,
anche perché
è morto alla fine del 1933
e non ha fatto in tempo
a vedere molto,
però quello che si sa
è che da un lato
i nazisti
li trovava un po' disgustosi.
Li chiama
questi boia.
Però, però, però
l'idea che la Germania
finalmente si risollevi,
anche se deve essere
questo imbianchino Hitler
che la riporta su,
ecco,
a Stefan Gheorghe
forse non dispiaceva tanto,
ma insomma
lui muore,
gli altri restano.
Kantorowicz
nella prima parte
della sua vita
e forse in tutta la sua vita
farà in tempo
a cambiare molte idee
come vedremo,
è influenzato profondamente
da quello che ha imparato
nell'ambiente
di Stefan Gheorghe.
Da un lato
molto probabilmente
è influenzato
in un senso
molto forte
e privato.
Stefan Gheorghe
è omosessuale
e ai suoi giovani allievi,
ai suoi giovani amici
predica
una vita di celibato,
quasi sacerdotale
come la sua.
Kantorowicz
non si è mai sposato,
è sempre rimasto
uno scapolone,
celibe,
ha sempre avuto
una grandissima riservatezza
sulla sua vita privata,
non sappiamo niente,
non ha lasciato niente
nei documenti,
non si sa nulla
del suo privato,
non ne ha mai parlato,
Salvemini
di cui abbiamo raccontato
l'altro ieri
ha scritto infiniti libri,
memorie di quando
ho fatto le elezioni,
memorie di quando,
ecco,
Kantorowicz
niente.
Di recente
c'è stata una polemica,
uno storico francese
Alain Bourreau
ha pubblicato
una biografia
di Kantorowicz,
adesso magari
questa cosa
che sto per dire
è un dettaglio marginale,
ma lo dico lo stesso
per darvi l'idea
del terreno
su cui ci stiamo muovendo,
Alain Bourreau
ha scritto
una biografia
di Kantorowicz,
ma non si sa niente
di Kantorowicz
in realtà,
Alain Bourreau
ha inventato,
o meglio,
ha detto,
è stato combattente
dei Frey Corps,
prendiamo le memorie
di altri combattenti
dei Frey Corps
e così proviamo a vedere
cosa poteva aver pensato
Kantorowicz
in quel momento.
In questo libro
Alain Bourreau,
questo libro
dal metodo discutibile
evidentemente,
Alain Bourreau
dice
tutti sapevano
in America
anticipo,
alla fine
lo porteremo in America
Kantorowicz
dove vedrete
cosa gli succede.
In America
nelle università americane
tutti sapevano
che Kantorowicz
era omosessuale.
Un allievo americano
di Kantorowicz
che poi è stato
suo collega
ha voluto intervenire
e puntualizzare.
Momento.
Sospettavamo
che fosse omosessuale
ma non l'ha mai saputo
nessuno.
Della sua vita privata
non si sapeva niente.
E questo sarebbe
il meno.
Kantorowicz
a noi interessa
perché è un grande storico
e nel circolo
di Stefan Georgi
ha imparato
questa cosa
che influenza
la sua carriera
all'inizio
dei grandi uomini
i grandi uomini
della storia tedesca
del passato.
Ce n'è uno
che gli interessa
più di tutti
e che interessa
anche a noi italiani
perché è l'imperatore
Federico II
di Svevia
che era più italiano
che tedesco
come lo stesso
Kantorowicz
sapeva benissimo.
si innamora
di Federico II
di Svevia.
Nel 1924
si festeggiano
i 700 anni
della fondazione
dell'Università
di Napoli
fondata
da Federico II
nel 1224.
700 anni dopo
nel 1924
Kantorowicz
e un gruppo
di giovani amici
tedeschi
fanno un pellegrinaggio
a Palermo
per portare
una corona
sulla tomba
di Federico II
e la corona
porta una dedica
all'imperatore Federico II
da parte
della Germania
segreta.
In Italia
Kantorowicz
dice
e scrive poi
a casa
qui gli italiani
sono tutti impazziti
per Federico II
sostanzialmente
sui giornali
si dice
prima di Mussolini
un altro grande
ha voluto
rendere imperiale
l'Italia
e così via
e Kantorowicz
ci sghignazza
abbastanza
questa idea
che gli italiani
e Mussolini
si vogliono
annettere
Federico II
fatto sta
che quella
è la sua passione
di quegli anni
e nel 1927
Kantorowicz
scrive
il suo libro
più famoso
ancora oggi
si trova tranquillamente
in libreria
in Italia
tradotto in italiano
che è la sua
biografia
dell'imperatore
Federico II
la biografia
di Federico II
esce
in una collana
diretta
da Stefan Georg
sui grandi uomini
del passato tedesco
una collana
sulla cui copertina
c'è una svastica
va detto
peraltro
che non c'erano
ancora i nazisti
e la svastica
non era ancora
stata appropriata
dai nazisti
era un simbolo
esoterico
che poteva andare bene
per tutti gli usi
cosa scrive
Kantorowicz
su Federico II
intanto
nella dedica
nell'introduzione
ricorda
quando la Germania
segreta
è andata
a rendergli omaggio
sulla sua tomba
a Palermo
e dice
noi dobbiamo
dobbiamo ricordarci
dei grandi
imperatori tedeschi
del passato
proprio
in questa epoca
senza più
imperatori
di nuovo
capiamoci
il trauma
che è stato
per la Germania
che era un impero
trovarsi di colpo
ridotta
a una repubblica
mica per niente
Hitler
il suo stato
lo chiamerà
il terzo
reich
cioè il terzo
impero
perché sa benissimo
che questa cosa
di non essere un reich
di non essere un impero
ai tedeschi
non è andata giù
proprio in questa epoca
senza più
imperatori
che è una frase
che va benissimo
nel 1927
ma non l'ha inventata
lui
in realtà
è un'espressione
di Schiller
di più di cento anni
prima
in Germania
è proverbiale
vuol dire
brutti tempi
Schiller diceva
questa età
senza imperatori
spaventosa
dunque
nostalgia
per un passato
in cui la Germania
era un grande impero
e vabbè
l'abbiamo capito
questo
adesso
magari mi capiterà
di ripeterlo
ancora qualche volta
ma insomma
ci siamo intesi
ma c'è anche qualcosa
di più
perché Cantorovic
è pur sempre
quello che ha fatto
la tesi sulle corporazioni
nel mondo islamico
e il suo Federico II
non è un puro eroe tedesco
e basta
è un eroe tedesco
che però è mezzo italiano
mezzo siciliano
e che ha protetto
gli arabi
ha protetto gli ebrei
è un ponte
fra l'Oriente
e l'Occidente
Cantorovic
cerca altri uomini
dell'epoca
che siano grandi
come Federico II
secondo lui
chi sono?
San Francesco
Dante
un altro innamorato
dell'impero
come sapete
dunque italiani
il suo Federico II
è una figura mista
mediterranea
però è un super uomo
Cantorovic
ha letto il suo Nice
naturalmente
il super uomo
che si erge
al di sopra degli altri
questo libro
esce
di un giovane sconosciuto
e provoca
un putiferio
in Germania
viene attaccato
molto duramente
dagli vecchi storici
i quali
dicono in sostanza
è scritto molto bene
ma sono tutte
fantasie
notate che questo libro
grossissimo
non ha le note
a piedi pagina
sapete cosa vuol dire
per noi del mestiere
questa cosa
la nota a piedi pagina
serve a dire
questa notizia
l'ho trovata
in quella fonte
il collega
può andare a controllare
ma se tu pubblichi
un enorme libro
dove Federico II
viene fuori
come una figura
strabordante
mitica
il primo uomo
del rinascimento
una leggenda vivente
e non ci sono le note
gli storici tedeschi
gli fanno
delle recensioni
spaventose
dicendo
il giovanotto
è molto in gamba
promette bene
però questa roba qui
non è storia
è fantasia
è uno sguardo mitico
si è inventato
le cose
Tantorovic è uno
che quando ci si mette
non ne lascia passare
nessuna
risponde in due modi
in primo luogo
risponde con degli articoli
in cui spiega
agli storici più vecchi
che il mito
e la leggenda
fanno parte
delle cose
che noi dobbiamo studiare
basta con gli storici
ricordate Bloch
ecco
è la stessa epoca
sono gli stessi anni
delle annale
di Marc Bloch
e Lucien Fevre
non basta più
studiare le guerre
i fatti
gli avvenimenti
Bloch vuole studiare
anche la marmellata
come ricorderà
qualcuno di voi
da ieri
Kantorovic vuole studiare
anche i miti
le leggende
questa è verità storica
scrive
l'altro modo
in cui
risponde ai suoi detrattori
che si mette al lavoro
e pubblica
un secondo volume
grande quanto il primo
solo di note
dove ci sono
tutte le note
di tutte le cose
che aveva detto
nel primo volume
dopo di che
quello è un mondo
in cui i professori
universitari
sono ancora pochi
gli studiosi
sono scarsi
in tutti i paesi
scarseggiano
e vengono apprezzati
per questo libro
nel 1930
l'università
di Francoforte
gli offre un posto
di professore
onorario
senza stipendio
poi vediamo
non è una grande
università prestigiosa
Francoforte
sono altre
ma insomma
lui accetta
tanto è ricco
di famiglia
dopo due anni
gli danno
la cattedra
vera e propria
con stipendio
come sempre
le date
che scandiscono
queste nostre
chiacchierate
ecco bisogna
starci attenti
no?
è appena diventato
professore universitario
Hitler
va al potere
e qui
viene fuori
una cosa
che chi di voi
ha letto il programma
sa già ma che io stasera
come dire
mi sono preso la libertà
di non anticiparvi
quando Hitler
va al potere
si scopre
che il professor
Kantorowicz
alto borghese
ricco
nazionalista
veterano del fronte
combattente
contro i comunisti
ferito
combattendo
contro i comunisti
conservatore tedesco
che idealizza
i grandi tedeschi
del passato
è ebreo
e il fatto
che sia ebreo
fino a quel momento
non gli aveva dato
nessun fastidio
e adesso
che Hitler
è andato
al potere
di colpo
diventa
un problema
Kantorowicz
deve decidere
cosa fare
voi forse
sapete
che la politica
del nazismo
nei confronti
degli ebrei
procede per piccoli
passi
si va un po'
per volta
una leggina
che gli toglie
qualche diritto
un'altra leggina
che gli impedisce
qualche cosa
però gli ebrei tedeschi
non vengono ammazzati
tutti quanti
appena Hitler
va al potere
tutt'altro
Hitler comincerà
a sterminare
gli ebrei polacchi
e russi
in piena
seconda guerra mondiale
e gli ebrei tedeschi
saranno ancora
in gran parte
in Germania
senza che nessuno
li abbia ancora
veramente toccati
anche se le leggi
li stanno
ecco
è una cosa
molto paradossale
che non sempre
ricordiamo
si comincia
quindi a piccoli passi
e all'inizio
si dice
però gli ebrei
che sono patrioti
gli ebrei
che hanno fatto
la guerra
quelli non li tocchiamo
quindi il professor
Kantorovic
non dovrebbe
essere toccato
lui però
è molto perplesso
e decide
di chiedere
il congedo
non si dimette
vuole un po'
vedere cosa succede
scrive al rettore
di Francoforte
chiedendo un semestre
di congedo
la lettera
è datata
il 20 aprile
giorno del compleanno
di Hitler
nessuno ha mai saputo
se l'ha fatto apposta
per scherzo
o se
gli è venuto fuori
per caso
in questa lettera
in cui chiede il congedo
Kantorovic scrive
beh intanto
ricorda chi è lui
frontkamp
combattente del fronte
veterano dei
fra i corps
ha combattuto
i polacchi
i comunisti
la repubblica
dei consigli
a Monaco
dice io sono
un nazionalista
io sono d'accordo
con un governo
nazionalista
e sono sicuro
che i miei studenti
non verranno mai
a contestare
le mie lezioni
e tuttavia
finché
ogni ebreo
tedesco
solo per la sua
origine
deve passare
quasi per un
traditore
della patria
finché
ogni ebreo
in quanto tale
è considerato
di razza
inferiore
finché
il fatto
di avere
sangue
soprattutto
ebreo
nelle vene
comporterà
un difetto
morale
finché
ogni ebreo
tedesco
e di sentimenti
nazionalisti
dovrà
vergognarsi
del suo
patriottismo
e nasconderlo
fino ad allora
mi sembra
incompatibile
con la dignità
del docente
universitario
continuare
in questo
lavoro
che è fondato
solo
sulla verità
interiore
come vi ho detto
tendeva a prenderla
alta
una concezione
del mestiere
del docente
universitario
che vedremo
anche più avanti
Kantorowicz
nelle lettere
di quei mesi
lo si vede
che oscilla
come tanti
bravi tedeschi
devono aver
oscillato
perché voi
capite
questi qua
promettono
di riportare
la Germania
essere un grande
impero
quello che abbiamo
tutti aspettato
per 15 anni
è difficile
dire di no
d'altra parte
cosa sia il nazismo
si vede subito
Kantorowicz è
particolarmente
scandalizzato
da quella politica
nazista
che viene applicata
fin dall'inizio
e che si chiama
loro la chiamano
in tedesco
la gleichschaltung
l'allineamento
vale a dire
un solo partito
tutti gli altri
non c'è bisogno
una sola istituzione
gli scout
non servono
ci sono i giovani
del partito
tutte le istituzioni
devono allinearsi
e fondersi
dentro quelle naziste
in una lettera
di Kantorowicz
a un collega
un altro famoso
medievista tedesco
lo Schram
che poi sarà
nazista invece
ecco Kantorowicz
scrive
io guarda
in questo momento
per me sarebbe più facile
occuparmi
di mineralogia
piuttosto che
di storia medievale
perché il dodecaedro
rimane un dodecaedro
e sotto nessun regime
può essere allineato
in un ottaedro
però un'altra lettera
al suo maestro
Stefan Georg
che è ancora vivo
in quei mesi
si vede che c'è anche
l'altro atteggiamento
e cioè
e se davvero
la Germania risorge
con questi qua
a me non mi vogliono
perché sono ebreo
però
però forse
siccome io sono
un patriota tedesco
forse dovrei
appoggiarli lo stesso
è una lettera
curiosa e imbarazzante
per questo vi leggo
un brano
dice a Stefan Georg
il suo maestro
possa la Germania
diventare
come il maestro
la immaginava
e se i fatti
di oggi
cioè Hitler
non sono solo
una parodia
di quella visione
quella visione
che noi avevamo
la Germania guidata
dagli eletti
ma se invece
segnano la vera strada
per realizzarlo
tutto può ancora
finire bene
e poi sentite questo
e allora
non importa
se l'individuo
può seguire
questa strada
cioè procedere
insieme con la Germania
nazista
verso il glorioso futuro
non importa
se l'individuo
può seguirla
anche lui
o meglio
se gli è permesso
o se invece
di applaudire
deve starsene
da parte
in quanto
soggetto
ebreo
o di colore
come si dice
adesso
dove cita
ovviamente
la fraseologia
dei primi decreti
che discriminano
in sostanza
io ho voluto
leggervelo
ma capite
cosa vuol dire
vuol dire
che per un attimo
si è detto
anche se a me
non mi vogliono
perché sono ebreo
che vadano pure avanti
perché così
la Germania
tornerà
alla gloria
e alla potenza
di una volta
non sa bene
cosa fare
ha chiesto il congedo
la burocrazia
ci mette un po'
non glielo danno subito
nel novembre del 33
ricomincia
l'anno accademico
e Stefan Georg
Stefan Georg
addio
Ernst Kantorowicz
riprende
le sue lezioni
la prima lezione
che fa a Francoforte
a quell'anno
è sul tema
della Germania segreta
dove racconta
di questa Germania segreta
degli eletti
fa una lezione
confusissima
nessuno capisce niente
però gli studenti
nazisti capiscono
non è dei nostri
perché in questa lezione
Kantorowicz
ci ha messo dentro
qualche battutina
tipo
i veri capi
della Germania segreta
non fanno vedere
i loro ritratti
per la strada
non si mescolano
con la folla
delle piazze
chissà cosa pensava
di fare
fatto sta
che gli studenti nazisti
sei mesi prima
aveva scritto
sono sicuro
che i miei studenti
non mi contesteranno mai
invece gli studenti nazisti
cominciano a contestarlo
duramente
tanto che dopo un po'
il rettore
gli dice
senti Kantorowicz
sospendiamo
le tue lezioni
te lo mandiamo subito
il congedo
vai
e per un po'
non farti vedere
in giro
nell'ultima lettera
a Stefan Georg
del 33
Stefan Georg
morirà pochi giorni dopo
Kantorowicz
finalmente dice
sono disgustato
sconvolto
addolorato
li odio
è leggermente isterico
quando ci si mette
ma insomma
se non altro
gli danno il congedo
vi racconto questa cosa
giusto per il gusto
dell'aneddoto
dove va in congedo
a Oxford
è già uno studioso
molto famoso
lo invitano a Oxford
a Oxford
incontra
un collega
che si chiama
Marc Bloch
passano una bella serata
insieme
Marc Bloch
scrive al suo amicone
Lucien Fevre
ho visto anche Kantorowicz
l'uomo di Federico II
l'imperatore
che ha una storia curiosa
è sempre Marc Bloch
che racconta
a quanto si dice
l'hanno accolto
a Oxford
per sbaglio
perché appartiene
lo ripeto anche qui
così si dice
a quella piccola
percentuale
di non ariani
che i nazisti
hanno deciso
di conservare
e in effetti
è vero
fino a quel momento
non l'hanno licenziato
è lui che ha chiesto
il congedo
dopodiché Bloch
da questo giudizio
di Kantorowicz
un po' sospetto
un po' troppo gentile
e si prende
un po' troppa confidenza
di sicuro
chi c'era ieri
si ricorda
che Marc Bloch
non dava del tuo a nessuno
ma intelligente
vivace
nient'affatto
Herr Professor
caso vuole
che un po' di anni
molti anni dopo
nel 61
Bloch è già morto
da un pezzo
Kantorowicz ormai
è anziano anche lui
esce su un giornale
un articolo
dove si parla
di Bloch
e si dice che Kantorowicz
è stato molto influenzato
da Bloch
Kantorowicz scrive
al giornale
e noi abbiamo
questa lettera
è un caso fantastico
perché racconta
la stessa serata
come l'ha vissuta lui
ho incontrato
Marc Bloch
a Oxford
ho cenato con lui
nel 1934
a Oriel
che è uno dei college
di Oxford
e sono rimasto
a parlare con lui
fino alle ore piccole
dopo che il nostro
gentile ospite
Sir Morris Poick
importante medievista
inglese dell'epoca
ci ebbe lasciati soli
con un buon rifornimento
di Bordeaux e whisky
qui voi mi scuserete
se lo storico
che io sono
ha un piccolo brivido
di nostalgia
per il modo
in cui vivevano
gli storici
degli anni 30
ecco
vabbè
entrambi
Cantorovic
che racconta
l'incontro con Bloch
entrambi ci siamo
così eccitati
nel corso
della conversazione
che non stavamo seduti
ma in piedi
davanti al caminetto
a scambiarci
argomentazioni
su quasi
ogni soggetto
possibile
chissà cosa avrebbe detto
se avesse saputo
che Bloch
ha detto
sì un po' viscido
ma insomma
vabbè
comunque
Cantorovic
finisce dicendo
però voi ragazzi
sbagliate a dire
che mi ha influenzato
molto
Bloch era un grande
ma non mi ha
influenzato tanto
perché lui aveva
questa passione
interiore
questo fuoco
è una cosa
che io non sono mai
riuscito ad avere
Cantorovic
si considera
come storico
ormai da vecchio
deve ancora fare
della strada
come vedremo
rispetto al Federico II
si considera
un freddo
non un passionale
come Mark Bloch
bene
fa un semestre
a Oxford
poi torna in Germania
in Germania
scopre che
lo riprenderebbero
anche all'università
però adesso
bisogna fare
il giuramento
di fedeltà a Hitler
e lui rifiuta
e va
in pensionamento
anticipato
qui c'è un piccolo
dettaglio
di quelli surreali
su come funziona
il mondo
forse la Germania
in particolare
il professor Cantorovic
va in pensionamento
anticipato
è ebreo
ma è un ebreo tedesco
fatto sta
che l'università
poi emigrerà in America
più tardi
l'università
di Francoforte
continua a pagargli
la pensione
in America
fino al 1941
quando Hitler
dichiara guerra
all'America
finalmente smettono
di mandargli
la pensione
in California
però fino a quel momento
gliela mandano
va in America
vi dicevo
non subito
è un testardo
prova a restare
in Germania
fino al 38
resta in Germania
viaggia
prende appunti
scrive un grande libro
poi quando si prepara
andare dall'editore
per pubblicarlo
esce una nuova leggina
nel 38
che vieta agli ebrei
di pubblicare libri
a questo punto
non ne può più
è abbastanza famoso
ha degli inviti
in America
parte
va in America
gennaio 39
è lì
prima a Baltimora
poi a Berkeley
in California
si fa qualche anno
di gavetta
nel 45
gli danno
la cattedra
a Berkeley
arrivando in America
Kantorowicz
è un altro uomo
una cosa
che colpisce
chi lo conosceva prima
e che colpisce
noi
che leggiamo
le cose che lui scrive
il nazionalista tedesco
che era da giovane
adesso
non ne può più
della Germania
gli sono cadute
tutte le illusioni
diventa molto antitedesco
anzi
cambia perfino
la pronuncia del nome
perché in Germania
pronunciava Kantorowicz
che per i tedeschi
suona meglio
in America
comincia a pronunciare
Kantorowicz
che invece funziona meglio
per gli americani
ripudia il suo libro
su Federico II
al diavolo
i grandi tedeschi
del passato
quando gli parlano
di quel libro
dice quel bastardo
non parla dell'imperatore
parla del libro proprio
in un'occasione
dice
l'autore di quel libro
è morto molti anni fa
il libro è famosissimo
gli propongono
di ristamparlo
lui si oppone
con questo ragionamento
mi risulta
che quel libro
Goering
lo ha mandato in regalo
a Mussolini
con dedica
e che Himmler
lo teneva sul comodino
perciò quel libro
non lo ristampate
qualcuno si stupisce
di come ha fatto
in fretta a cambiare
abbiamo una citazione
curiosa di un altro
ebreo tedesco
che arriva in America
negli anni della guerra
un filosofo
Karl Löwitt
anche lui esule
dalla Germania
arriva a Berkeley
nel 41
e nel suo diario
annota
Eucalipti
bellissima vista
sulla Baia
sapete che l'università
di Berkeley
sta vicino a San Francisco
sulla Baia di San Francisco
posto meraviglioso
vado a trovare
Kantorowicz
che ora ha scambiato
la Germania segreta
con la California
e dice
beh comunque
dopodiché
quello che vede
Löwitt
a casa di Kantorowicz
è
un'infinità
di bottiglie
di liquore
in una grottesca
villa
da diva
del cinema
quindi la California
ha le sue caratteristiche
ovviamente
Kantorowicz
ci si tuffa
a corpo morto
o
siccome si rischia
di scherzare troppo
ma lui era un uomo strano
eh
comunque in questi anni
in cui vive
la vita del divo
di Hollywood
insegnando a Berkeley
poi dalle sue carte
viene fuori
che
molti altri
e anche lui
a un certo punto
si stanno dando
da fare
per ottenere
un visto americano
per i suoi parenti
che sono rimasti
in Germania
perché lui
ha lasciato in Germania
la mamma
una cugina
Gertrude
che è una poetessa
abbastanza famosa
una cuginetta
ve l'ho detto
che sappiamo poco
di lui
è venuto in America
mollando tutti
in Germania
non sappiamo
cosa hanno pensato
però poi
quando è sistemato
in America
comincia a trafficare
per ottenere il visto
ma ormai
è troppo tardi
moriranno
tutte e tre
nel campo di concentramento
di Theresienstadt
che come sapete
è quel campo
di concentramento
modello
riservato agli ebrei
per bene
tedeschi
dove andava
anche la croce rossa
e dove però
quelli portati lì
bene o male
sono morti tutti
finalmente
in un modo o nell'altro
comunque ecco
dopodiché
non sappiamo
quanto si è preoccupato
per tutto questo
non sappiamo niente
di cosa pensava lui
veramente
di tante cose
ma
sappiamo che a Berkeley
diventa una star
il professor Kantorowicz
è adorato
dai suoi studenti
e non solo
dal mondo intellettuale
di San Francisco
i suoi studenti
ricordano
ma venivano poeti
scrittori
artisti
economisti
a sentire le sue lezioni
era un uomo
talmente colto
qui devo anticipare
un tema
che poi tornerà fuori
fra poco
è un europeo
e gli intellettuali
americani
in quegli anni
hanno ancora
un complesso
di inferiorità
quello che arriva
dall'Europa
gli sa
e poi Kantorowicz
è un uomo coltissimo
sa tutto
insomma
li sbalordisce
è un grande padrone
di casa
che invita volentieri
in questa sua villa
da diva di Hollywood
per l'appunto
grande cuoco
esperto di vini
ecco
aveva un soprannome
E.K.
che sarebbe
la pronuncia tedesca
delle sue iniziali
E.K.
ve lo dico
perché sappiamo
così poco
dell'intimità
di quest'uomo
che già un dettaglio
così
vuol dire qualcosa
gli amici
lo chiamavano
E.K.
e c'è un aneddoto
di un amico
che un giorno
è a casa sua
Kantorowicz
sta partendo
per un viaggio
l'amico
vede che mette
in valigia
una scatola
di tartufi
dice così
non so bene
se fosse un barattolo
comunque
dice una scatola
di tartufi
e l'amico
gli dice
E.K.
ma devi fare
un regalo?
E Kantorowicz
risponde
ah no
non viaggio mai
senza tartufi
è un grandissimo
amante di vini
in un'America
che conosce
ancora poco
il vino
a quell'epoca
per cui
tutti lo ammirano
è un conoscitore
a tal punto
vi racconto
ancora questo aneddoto
anche se è un aneddoto
sciocco
quando avrà 60 anni
nel 55
i suoi amici
vogliono fargli
un regalo
fra questi amici
c'è un grandissimo
storico dell'arte
Erwin Panofsky
anche lui
ebreo tedesco
figlio di industriali
scappato in America
cioè insomma
gli amici poi si trovano
fra loro
Panofsky è un grande
storico dell'arte
dice facciamogli
una medaglia
d'argento
con una raffigurazione
classica
ho trovato
un'antica medaglia
che raffigura
la dea Atena
dea della scienza
e il dio Bacco
dio del vino
glieli mettiamo
insieme sulla medaglia
con una scritta
del tipo
stanno bene insieme
o una cosa così
in latino
poi Kantorowicz
quando lo viene a sapere
dice no no no
io non voglio festeggiamenti
non voglio regali
non voglio che si parli di me
niente
non gliela lascia fare
dopodiché
in California
si trova così bene
che spesso
gli capita
di confidare
agli amici
questa
è la mia ultima casa
non dovrò
mai più
traslocare
e invece
la storia
è ancora lì
che lo aspetta
al varco
perché nel marzo
succede
cosa sta succedendo
al mondo
guerra fredda
maccartismo
in America
l'isteria anticomunista
la caccia alle streghe
il comitato di McCarty
per trovare i comunisti
nel
succede una storia
che adesso vi racconterò
per tutto quel quarto d'ora
che ci rimane di lezione
quindi prendetevela comoda
perché la storia
è la storia cruciale
con cui si conclude
la vicenda di Cantorovice
che dà un altro senso
alla sua figura
il consiglio di amministrazione
dell'università
della California
decide di fare
una bella figura
in questo momento
in cui il paese
è in lotta
contro il comunismo
decidendo
che ogni professore
dell'università
dovrà prestare
ogni anno
uno speciale giuramento
in cui garantisce
di non essere
un sovversivo
un comunista
o cose del genere
qui vi do
un piccolo dettaglio
per capire la situazione
le università
l'università della California
a Berkeley e Los Angeles
è un'università statale
non è la tipica
università privata americana
è dello stato
della California
le università americane
all'epoca
sono già benedette
da quella cosa meravigliosa
che noi non avevamo
fino a pochissimo tempo fa
e che invece
è stata regalata
anche alle nostre
università italiane
con l'ultima riforma
un consiglio di amministrazione
formato non dai professori
ma da esponenti
del mondo politico
e della cosiddetta
società civile
in Italia oggi
non è detto
all'epoca in America
in genere queste persone
non sanno niente
di cos'è l'università
ma la devono gestire
nel consiglio di amministrazione
di Berkeley
ci sono
il governatore
della California
miliardari
assortiti
banchieri
avvocati
di miliardari
e così via
l'ammiraglio
Chester Nimitz
che ha vinto
la battaglia delle Midway
e che hanno messo lì
per bellezza
questo corpo
dei reggenti
dell'università
della California
decide che tutti i professori
dovranno prestare
questo giuramento
di fedeltà
non credo
e non sono membro
né sostengo
alcun partito
o organizzazione
che propone
o insegna
il rovesciamento
del governo
degli Stati Uniti
con la forza
o la violenza
al consiglio di amministrazione
sembra una cosa
normalissima
è ovvia
l'intera America
sta lottando
contro il comunismo
ci sono alcuni
piccoli paradossi
che io stesso
non sapevo
e ho scoperto
preparando questa
chiacchierata
per esempio
che il partito
comunista
negli Stati Uniti
non è illegale
esiste legalmente
e i cittadini
hanno diritto
di farne parte
però
c'è un consenso
diffuso
che se sei comunista
non puoi essere
impiegato dello Stato
insegnante
e così via
e questo
sono più o meno
tutti d'accordo
i professori
dell'Università
della California
sono nel complesso
conservatori
anticomunisti
però
questa cosa
che il consiglio
di amministrazione
si è inventato
per far bella figura
improvvisamente
scatena
una catastrofe
che nessuno
si immaginava
tanto per cominciare
si crea
una certa atmosfera
di sospetto
i professori
dicono
ma perché
noi
dobbiamo firmare
e tutti gli altri
i bagnini
delle piscine pubbliche
l'opinione pubblica
dice
ah ma allora
all'Università
della California
si sono infiltrati
i comunisti
la stampa
comincia a battere
qui
questa università
c'è qualcosa
di marcio
notate che
i professori
sono funzionari
dello Stato
della California
e hanno già
prestato un giuramento
di fedeltà
alla Costituzione
che dovrebbe bastare
molti di loro
dicono
ma scusate
ma un giuramento
che si rifà
ogni anno
secondo voi
è più forte
ma neanche per idea
qualcun altro
dice
ma ragazzi
ma secondo voi
se uno è davvero
comunista
arriva lì
e dice
ah no
io non posso
firmare
perché sono
comunista
ma scherzate
si crea
questo clima
e
la maggioranza
anzi
la grande maggioranza
dei professori
comincia a dire
no
noi questa cosa
non va bene
devono ritirarla
non siamo d'accordo
noi rispondiamo
alla nostra coscienza
e basta
nessuno si aspetta
che il professor
Kantorowicz
viveur
intenditore
di vini
e così via
si scaldi
molto
per questa cosa
i suoi studenti
anzi
lo considerano
uno che di politica
non capisce niente
ci sono testimonianze
che dicono
è proprio incredibile
eca
è una testa
così geniale
completamente
fuori dal mondo
lo stesso Kantorowicz
dichiara
alla prima occasione
e continua a dichiarare
a ogni occasione
io sono un vero conservatore
e nessuno
mi ha mai scambiato
per nient'altro
dopodiché
questo vero conservatore
ferito
combattendo
contro i comunisti
eccetera
si alza
in senato accademico
e fa
uno straordinario
discorso
in cui dice
queste robe qua
le hanno fatte
Mussolini in Italia
e Hitler in Germania
a voi sembra
che sia una cosa da niente
questo giuramento
certo
chi di noi
è un sovversivo
nessuno
e quindi uno dice
cosa sarà mai
firmiamo
ma dice
io sono uno storico
io ne ho visti
tanti giuramenti
nella storia
voi non sapete
come funziona
si fa un giuramento
che sembra innocuo
poi dopo un po' di tempo
si aggiunge una paroletta
se ne toglie un'altra
si cambia un verbo
non sono mai stato
diventa
non sarò mai
e così via
e non puoi più
tornare indietro
è il primo giuramento
che bisogna
evitare
tenete conto
che Cantorovici
anche se adesso
la cattedra
ce l'ha da pochi anni
non è certo un privilegiato
non ha ancora
la cittadinanza americana
avrebbe potuto benissimo
starsene bravo e zitto
e invece
si dice
no
questa cosa
non si può fare
e Cantorovici dice
ragazzi guardate
che se si comincia così
e poi
chi decide
chi è un sovversivo
io sono uno storico
vi posso dire
che c'è stata un'epoca
in cui per i cattolici
i protestanti
erano tutti sovversivi
e per i protestanti
i cattolici
erano tutti sovversivi
e un giorno
i repubblicani
potrebbero dire
che i democratici
sono sovversivi
e viceversa
non bisogna
cominciare
e poi soprattutto
dice
sono tanti i motivi
per cui sono sconcertati
questi professori
e io
il grande dubbio
che avevo stasera
era se riesco a darvi un'idea
di come questa roba
che sembra una robetta
sia una cosa che invece
dal punto di vista
della coscienza
per loro
è una cosa grossissima
perché è una questione
di principio
io devo rendere conto
al consiglio di amministrazione
delle mie opinioni politiche
ma io rendo conto
alla mia coscienza
e a Dio
se ci credo
delle mie opinioni politiche
non al consiglio
di amministrazione
e se il consiglio
mi dice
firma
se no ti caccio
allora questo è un ricatto
e se io cedo
al ricatto
con che faccia
vado poi davanti
ai miei studenti
che sanno
che io sono lì
solo perché
ho fatto una cosa
contro la mia coscienza
per non perdere
la pagnotta
ho cominciato
fin dall'inizio
dicendovi che Cantorovic
è uno che tende
a prendere le alte
le cose
ma questa cosa
qui
la prendono alta
tutti
questa crisi
scatena nel mondo
universitario americano
un conflitto
che è passato
alla storia
l'anno del giuramento
ci sono intere biblioteche
di libri e studi
su cosa è successo
l'anno del giuramento
tanto per cominciare
succede che Cantorovic
aveva ragione
una settimana dopo
il testo del giuramento
cambia
adesso bisogna anche
dichiarare
che non si hanno
impegni
in conflitto
con la propria responsabilità
e cosa vuol dire
però tu devi giurarlo
e c'è anche scritto
finalmente
chiaro e tondo
che giurare
è la condizione
per avere lo stipendio
Cantorovic
scrive a un collega
puoi anche includermi
fra quelli
così
che tutti accusano
di orgoglio accademico
di essere solo
dei professori
presuntuosi
o puoi chiamarmi
un ebreo
o un tedesco
idealista
ma io sono
e cerco di essere
sia come ebreo
che come tedesco
anche un eterno
nemico
dei barbari
non importa
se la barbarie
sia bruna
o nera
o rossa
e se si manifesti
con la brutta faccia
di mister Stalin
di mister Hitler
o del consiglio
di amministrazione
dell'università
dopodiché
comincia
una durissima polemica
sui giornali
ovviamente ci sono
i giornali conservatori
che dicono
vedete
sono tutti comunisti
i professori di Berkeley
gli studenti
sconcertati
la stampa progressista
che invece
prende posizione
dall'altra parte
e Kantorovic
che interviene
continuamente
nella polemica
sui giornali
toccando una serie
di punti
dice
questi qua
del consiglio
di amministrazione
hanno detto
che noi siamo
solo degli ingenui
professori
fuori dal mondo
che non abbiamo
idea
della minaccia
comunista
se io veramente
ho combattuto
contro i comunisti
tre volte
col fucile in mano
magari ne so
qualcosa di più
che non questi signori
del consiglio
di amministrazione
dice anche
il consiglio
di amministrazione
ritiene
di poterci
licenziare
come vuole
in sostanza
ci considera
dei dipendenti
del consiglio
di amministrazione
stesso
come se fossimo
gli usceri
o i giardinieri
qui c'è una cosa
molto delicata
perché
del resto
io sono qui
a raccontarvi
cosa pensa Kantorovic
mica a dire
se aveva ragione
o no
Kantorovic
dice
un momento
noi non siamo
i dipendenti
del consiglio
di amministrazione
noi siamo
l'università
noi e gli studenti
siamo l'università
così come
i vescovi
e i fedeli
sono la chiesa
avete mai visto
un vescovo
che picchetta
una chiesa
così un professore
non picchetta
l'aula
non è sindacalizzato
all'epoca si usava così
perché non ha
una controparte
un datore di lavoro
contro cui combattere
noi siamo
l'università
si può immaginare
un'università
senza neanche
un giardiniere
o un uscere
si può immaginare
un'università
senza neanche
una segretaria
e perfino
visione meravigliosa
senza neanche
un consiglio
di amministrazione
ma non si può
immaginare
un'università
senza professori
e studenti
il consiglio di amministrazione
tiene duro
entro il primo ottobre
49 bisogna firmare
Kantorovic
non firma
e scrive una lettera
dove dice
io
mi sono arruolato
volontario due volte
per combattere
i comunisti
ma ho anche capito
che in quel modo lì
senza volerlo
ho aperto la strada
ai nazisti
adesso
non sono più disposto
a compromessi
la faccio breve
il consiglio di amministrazione
prima dice
vabbè dai
facciamo un compromesso
appunto
chi non firma
verrà esaminato
dal senato accademico
e se il senato accademico
trova che non è un comunista
può restare
una trentina
non firmano
un mese dopo
il consiglio di amministrazione
si rimangia tutto
e li licenzia
con una discussione
molto violenta
in cui qualcuno dice
ma allora li licenziamo
perché cosa
non sono certo comunisti
questi qua lo sanno tutti
li licenziamo
perché s'hanno disubbidito
la faccenda
si è ridotta
a questo
il consiglio di amministrazione
vuole comandare
e i professori
non vogliono che comandi
in 26
tengono duro
e vengono licenziati
tra loro ci sono due italiani
lo dico così
per dettaglio
Leonardo Olschchi
storico
ebreo
italiano
e un fisico nucleare
Giancarlo Vic
ora
quello che
va sottolineato
per arrivare
avviarci la conclusione
è che questa vicenda
che non è finita
la vicenda
perché a questo punto
la lotta continua
come si dirà poi
in epoca successiva
è che
il mondo
universitario
americano
è di mezzo mondo
in realtà
sta guardando
allibito
quello che succede
a Berkeley
i giornali americani
i più progressisti
sono sconvolti
il New York
Herald Tribune
scrive
questa università
va incontro al disastro
e la cosa più comica
è che nessuno
pensa che ci siano davvero
dei comunisti
fra i professori
neanche il consiglio
di amministrazione
lo pensa
ma soprattutto
quello che succede
è che
da tutte le parti
arrivano misure
di solidarietà
nei confronti
dei licenziati
parecchie altre università
passano un accordo
per cui i professori
rinunciano
a una piccola quota
di stipendio
per creare un fondo
per sostenere
i licenziati
da Princeton
che è Princeton
arriva una lettera
di questo tenore
naturalmente
qui siamo tutti
scioccati
dalla superstizione
medievale
o dobbiamo dire
sovietica
del vostro consiglio
di amministrazione
tutta una serie
di grandi studiosi
che vengono
invitati a Berkeley
perché voi sapete
adesso qui stiamo
parlando di Berkeley
che attraversa
una crisi pazzesca
in questo momento
ma l'università americana
è un corpo straordinario
di un'apertura
e di una ricchezza
specialmente
in quegli anni
e la sua potenza
è data anche
dal fatto
che in genere
è la qualità
degli studiosi
l'unica cosa
che conta
e le università
fanno appugni
per strapparsi
gli studiosi
più in gamba
a Berkeley
scoprono
una cosa sconcertante
scrivono
a un grande fisico
per offrirgli
una cattedra
e il grande fisico
risponde
no scusate
io a Berkeley
non ci vengo
scrivono
a un grande scrittore
Robert Penn Warren
uno dei più grandi scrittori
di quel momento
in America
offrendogli di venire
a tenere delle lezioni
a Berkeley
Penn Warren
scrive
mi dispiace
a Berkeley
non ci vengo
e ho i miei motivi
e anzi scriverò
i giornali
per spiegare
perché non ci vengo
perché lì
la libertà accademica
non esiste più
da quando
se non firmi
quello che ti dice
il consiglio di amministrazione
vieni licenziato
il risultato
è che l'università
di Berkeley
sprofonda
nel caos
i professori
che mancano
non possono essere
sostituiti
i studenti
smettono di iscriversi
moltissimi corsi
devono essere aboliti
ci sono dei paradossi
tre dei dimissionari
sono i tre principali
fisici
del dipartimento
di fisica nucleare
hanno fatto
la bomba atomica
hanno tutti
i certificati
della CIA
e dell'FBI
al più alto livello
possono conoscere
tutti i segreti militari
degli Stati Uniti
e li licenziano
perché non firmano
il giuramento
che loro non sono comunisti
il dipartimento
di fisica nucleare
va a rotoli
saltano i contratti
perché naturalmente
le università americane
fanno ricerca
e fanno ricerca
col privato
con i loro laboratori
e hanno contratti
miliardari
ma se quel fisico
a cui volevo fare
quel lavoro
da un milione di dollari
non c'è più
io il contratto
lo straccio
e tutta l'America
guarda
l'università di Berkeley
che da grandissima
università di punta
è diventata
la burletta
di tutti gli Stati Uniti
scrive il San Francisco
Chronicle
e di nuovo
per dirvi che appunto
a noi oggi
possono sembrare cose da poco
rispetto ai problemi
che abbiamo oggi
nella nostro paese
nella nostra università
gli americani
del 1950
in piena guerra fredda
l'hanno presa
come una cosa serissima
perché la coscienza
evidentemente
per loro
era una cosa serissima
San Francisco Chronicle
questa vicenda
ha portato
al disastro
intellettuale
e morale
una grande università
siamo avviati
al peggiore
disastro
mai sperimentato
dal sistema
educativo americano
dopodiché
cosa succede?
succede che i nostri
licenziati
fanno causa
e la Corte Suprema
della California
decide che hanno ragione
loro
che il Consiglio
di Amministrazione
ha violato
la Costituzione
della California
pretendendo
di condizionare
la libertà
di coscienza
e nella sentenza
la Corte Suprema
della California
scrive
va benissimo
lottare contro
il pericolo comunista
ma stiamo anche
molto attenti
a non demolire
dall'interno
i principi
della nostra libertà
dopodiché
l'Università
di Berkeley
è costretta
a scrivere
a tutti quanti
dicendo
va bene
vi riassumiamo
solo che la grande
maggioranza
sono stati già
chiamati altrove
Kantorowicz
è stato chiamato
a Princeton
all'Institute
for Advanced Studies
cioè il vertice
del sistema
culturale americano
per capirci
il suo collega
è Einstein
a Princeton
di conseguenza
non torna
a Berkeley
hanno vinto
dunque
alla fine
e qui ho
stiamo veramente
concludendo
l'unico documento
un po' personale
che sono riuscito
a trovare
fra le carte
di Kantorowicz
non sono andato
a Princeton
ma l'archivio
di Kantorowicz
è online
migliaia di documenti
leggibili
quasi tutta roba
che riguarda
questa crisi
l'anno del giuramento
il leader
dei dissidenti
era uno psicologo
che si chiamava
Edward Tolman
uno psicologo
comportamentale
per capirci
uno di quelli
che all'epoca
facevano correre
i topini
nei labirinti
e gli davano
le scosse elettriche
per vedere
da che parte
andavano
e questo genere
di cose qua
Kantorowicz
scrive
a Edward Tolman
quando ha in mano
la sentenza
che gli dà ragione
per cui hanno vinto
la loro battaglia
beh Edward
eccoci qui
questa è la fine
del viaggio
poteva andare
peggio
in questi anni
siamo stati
per lo più
come i tuoi topi
di laboratorio
nel labirinto
che battono
il naso
ogni volta
ma un po'
per volta
abbiamo imparato
a restituire
le botte
spero che i tuoi topi
non impareranno mai
e abbiamo insegnato
la lezione
a quegli arroganti
politici
abbiamo vinto
per così dire
siamo più felici
adesso
ho i miei dubbi
un po'
di ingenuità
e di fiducia
in quello
che è giusto
fare
e cosa vale
la pena
di fare
ha sofferto
e si è rotta
e ci ha resi
un po'
cinici
perché né tu
né io
ci butteremmo
allegramente
un'altra volta
nella stessa battaglia
che strana creatura
è l'uomo
ma questo
tu lo sai meglio
di me
è stata una bella cosa
combattere insieme a te
Mein Führer
con affetto
e K
siamo alla fine
degli anni 50
gli restano pochi anni
muore nel 1963
di tumore
per testamento
lascia che desidera
di essere cremato
entro dieci ore
dalla morte
e di non avere
alcun funerale
da quando
sa di avere il cancro
e di essere in punto di morte
tutti rimangono
sbalorditi
da come la prende
dalla tranquillità
con cui la prende
tanto che dopo la morte
l'amico Panofsky
detta per lui
un epitafio
in latino
come si usava
anche Mark Bloch
l'avete visto
voleva un epitafio
in latino
che si conclude così
vitam amavit
mortem
non timuit
ha amato la vita
non ha temuto la morte
grazie
grazie a tutti
e arrivederci all'anno prossimo
a Sardana
grazie a tutti
Grazie a tutti